- Bara a quitté le Texas
pour rejoindre ses prochese e et
à sa troisième tentative.La temé
l'annulation de nombreux
trajets de VIA Rail. T T T T T à
Ottawa et de Toronto à Montréal
étaient annulés le 25 décembre.
n n n n n n n n n n n n n n n s
voyager." Mais vous savez,
lorsqu'il faut voyager,
il faut voyager.
- Pas
les voyageurs qui peinent
à arriver à destination.
- Oui, j'ai manqué mon Noël
avec mes enfants. Ça fait
je suis parti pour... Montréal,
on a pris le bus comme tous
les autres, mais on est...
on était bloqués au niveau
au moins une affaire
de six heures de temps.
GENEVIÈVE LAJOIE,
- Parce que tous les restaurants
étaient pleins de monde,
puis il y avait des personnes
les voitures.
- Devant la situation,
la mairesse de Casselman q q q e
de déclarer l'état d'urgence,
ce qui lui a, entre autres,
permis d'ouvrir des centres
- Plein de manger,
so le monde pouvait manger.
Là, c'était tous les matelas et,
ici, c'était tous  e e e e e e t
couchés sur ça.
- Un Noël inattendu,
mais en belle compagnie.eeeeeeee
quand ils sont partis,
parce que le monde était
tellement heureux, sentirauauau.
LUC MATTE, employé, Aréna
du Complexe J.R. Brisson
- Oui, le groupe était très,ala.
Il y en a qui ont été se coucher
tout de suite. On a eu de...
la bouffe, de la bonne bouffe.
de Noël, mais avec une nouvelle
famille, comme ils disent.
L'esprit de Noël était là,
était comme... un moment vécu
Ça... c'était chaud au coeur.
- L'état d'urgence à Casselman
est maintenu, question de
de garder ses centres
communautaires ouverts etesesess
nécessaires pour se relever
de la tempête.
Ici Rebecca Kwa